So sleep is actually a really organized process. Throughout the night, our
brain cycles between what we call rapid eye movement sleep or REM sleep and
non-REM sleep so not rapid eye movement sleep. Non-REM sleep Has four stages.
When we fall a sleep we go down to stage I, then to, three and four. Again,
this is our deepest sleep. But then when we cycle back up we go from four to
three to two and once we get back to one we go into rapid eye movement
sleep,and this is where dreams occur. Now, rapid eye movement sleep is exactly
what it sounds like, your eyes move back and forth really, really rapidly
underneath your eyelids. It's interesting to note that our electricity activity
during REM sleep looks pretty similar to when we're awake. Now, this whole
cycle lasts about 90 minutes. This means that about 25 percent of our sleep we
spend in rapid eye movement sleep. And 75 percent we spend outside of rapid eye
movement sleep.